en chaîne en être et pourquoi pas bleu
dans cette usine depuis un an et demi
Marie-Christine fait partie de ceux qui
donnent de la couleur au cercueil avec
une base blanche et quelques pigments
elle peut donner vie à 20
coloris on aime ce qu'on fait on est
plusieurs à le faire c'est vraiment
agréable et de voir après le le cercueil
terminé le vernis donc en plus ça brille
c'est c'est magnifique l'autre jour o on
a fait pour un supporter de lance un
cercueil jaune et rouge aux couleurs de
l'équipe de foot de lance une quinzaine
de cercueils colorés sont peints chaque
jour voyez tout toutes les couleurs que
vous
avez derrière chacun d'entre eux une
chaîne de production madeine franche
compté avec du bois provenant
directement des forêts situées autour de
l'usine dans cette boucle Maurice pfine
les derniers détails des caisses comme
il aime les appeler il en a vu passer et
pas des
moindres cue pour pour par exemple Miral
noir j'ai fait un H mesure de 1 m3 de
haut sur 90 de large pour une personne
de 330 kg 44 ans j'en ai vu j'en ai vu
défiler la demande est de plus en plus
importante de la part des familles avec
toujours cette volonté célébrer une vie
on se dit on veut quelque chose de plus
personnalisé de plus différents et qui
rendre plus le côté unique de l'individu
qui don dont c'est l'hommage et c'est un
moyen de le rendre malgré la
réglementation qui est assez stricte sur
les cercueils bah ça permet quand même
d'avoir déflorer les limites de ce qu'on
peut faire pour se dire il a eu un
hommage digne et qui était à son image
pour un cercueil personnalisé compter en
moyenne 200 € de plus que le prix
initial